[Risate]
ciao tutti bender netsuite nuova
challenge slide con la ruota a
grandissima richiesta e anche di tipo 1
2 3 questa volta abbiamo tre mistery box
che ogni turno cambieranno il loro
contenuto
no inseriremo la ruota erano perché
scappi tera 1 2 o 3
dovevamo aprire la mistery box e versare
il contenuto dentro una sola del rousse
live da poco però ci sono anche altri
figli con lei come sempre alla fine del
video dovrete votare ha deciso che non è
un giallo viking stand up e trova bene e
bottiglie l'inter è un po per il terzino
però lì io non si sono già in rosa per
video che sondaggio qua e potrete
portare chi ha vinto in base all those
line in modo nobel e tom cruise line e
inizia bene sempre avere una bocca che
vi ho finito con la simpatia del 40 se
ne vigoni quando si è d'accordo the caso
di tutti quello che volete lasciato in
bellezza
il pareggio con la ruota e siamo subito
più una domanda di cibo
se volete che la facciamo sempre se c'è
il cibo iniziati piano perfetto non ci
fu chi crede rincuorante verde quello po
verde menta verde acqua tiro seduta un
felice che non è capitato non si posso
credere che sicuramente sarà pubblicato
solo avendo già oddio il gruppo bene
nella frazione giacchio france perde
però potrebbero essercene altri quindi
io dico niente fortunato da herat a camp
e vediamo che ritengo la vigata
[Musica]
occhiobello numero 2 che però ora
ovviamente è cambiata alfabeti sarebbe
vuoto prendiamo un po tra l'altro a lui
che a scatola aperta quindi per i porti
sfortuna se letti etica parlando tutte
quando attivare questa nuova funzione è
stato è un verde rai
se pallina più bianco
non so perché ma il bianco e il celeste
sono belli piacciono un sacco
che bello già sarà un bellissimo se non
mi capita qualcosa di schifoso speriamo
bene è un po il tuo verdi invece come
diventa forse dovrei mettere di più
goyer diritti lo metteremo in verde sto
perché perché vi faremo che si scarica
grazie più verde ma che dice perché voi
che vivete verte chiarissimo perde a
manchester ma ho ben consigliato bello
con bird era ok tocca a vitale di un
giallo
[Musica]
uno stato che il club di moratti arriva
nel verde a cercare timorosa catania
numero tre videopoker s'incazza mistery
box numero 36 caps con la notte rosa che
si sta super bene qua anche uno pensa
ancora più grate e vino vero che andiamo
a tenere la nostra città pezzo esce il
super morbida e prosa ieri vi indico un
sacco di colla sembra color salmone
cosa sta aumentando lo sai che bello
[Musica]
oddio cos'è quella cosa
sarah uscì giu qua è un pezzo di
colorante se si verificasse il colorante
per zio stark si sciolga poi in tema con
la paletta già si è vero vediamo se
rimanero nostra under colore del mio
team ma che dai utilizzando oggi lo
chiamo numero è più verde milan tellina
di color giallo di forte di programmi da
questo è il play che hanno trovato nel
box non canzone diciamo si leggono
magari su un bel poster drive da un sito
che ti serve un programma fitto allora
corta diventando il tuo tempo ammuffita
così fortunato perché in genere la
situazione era contrario che io sono
perde ma veramente non so come possa
essere così fortunate che non ho beccato
in verde non fondati da solista ministro
non vanno toccati aiuto stava uscendo
cambio sul si va al cambio il passivo
allora finito per me e allora ecco
l'amore sono dei fili dei figli glitter
e colorati
e che sono i fili che si chiama stato
feeling del terreno
abbiamo perso come si chiamano tutti
fini colorati figurazioni noi diventiamo
attraverso i loro spinato che anche
unicorno sembra siano dei piccoli jazz
non possono costituirsi sempre
all'azienda di piccoli le piccole non si
guarda il click day
ma cosa significa superate le zie mister
è molto bello molto ben fatte è qui che
aspetto fin dall'inizio di strano che
due si stanno capitando a te è capitata
la spugnetta bridge likud
in realtà potrebbe starci benissimo
sr quindi potrebbe intendersi in realtà
poi tie dye magari diventa belli
capitale dubito niente tumi numero 2
ancora niente uno solo è possibile
finalmente vi è capitato belli che
vibrava l'ha fatta mente proprio credere
troppo bene ma staccata con la ditta con
la deliberata forse questo video e
l'audio klein musiche bel sacco di
colori dentro magari riesce davvero a
salvare il tuo line ma bellissimo il
colore nero con un milione di click è
uno se riesco a salvarlo forse diventa
grigio bonera 6 torturando quest'anno
nella lazio sta tutta lì a mischiarsi
con quello slide coprire tutto diventa
fantastica
ora me ne stanno uscendo tutti i
clippers ed è migliorato parecchio bello
colore mi sembra lo stesso però incalza
vede qualche bello su percorso tornare
adesso per colorato di tanti glitter
colorati dei colori
non ho ancora mischiato i fili come
volevo chiamati pillitteri glitterati
fili di trini qui leaderini oddio che
strano che lo fanno ma questa è senza un
po strana nel sesso c'è un malloppo qua
non so speriamo bene
tocca a mente che non se ne esce il
microfono finalmente che cultura
incredibile venire di spessore forse
fieramente facciamo la morte della bit
air box del numero 1 giu
[Musica]
amore mio marito ci stanno e venerdì si
tengono di vento mentre coloro che bene
le mette a capo chino sarà super tracce
sono triste tutto sommato questo costoso
dopo the bike in giallo numero tre di
cosa nostra
le fiches ball rosa senza prestargli
temi che avevano tutte lo scriverà tv
troppo lo slime o se se molti
ingredienti entrano dentro tipo il mieri
tesissimo nel caso non ti a casa dove la
palla quindi è difficile farle a dei
video tennis soprattutto con incrementi
a casa
[Musica]
occhi chiusi allora di tenere calcolare
allo scadere e io devo sì per l'acqua
bene cantieri questa
o siete la numero 1 quella che genere
non si sceglie cosa ci fate
[Musica]
palloncino misterioso affianca la
polizia ha visto bene ricordare che
cos'è che li aiutiamo scoppiamo questa
zucchetta oddio è tutto bianco ma vabbè
ma che latte latte di svezia
oddio ho molto latte di zucca finalmente
di stato l'ordinanza del suo sly che ne
stai magari lo fa a bellucci di bello se
ci riesco perché di mondello mirino lo
zio di frodo non la consistenza
stranissima quindi perso i propri cari
che è il pollicino con la pagina però è
acqua
ci sarà molto facile da attirare alla
fine è spartana che ha preferito però
prima di cresciuto dal cane sai magari
io devo cambiamo gallerie non lo dire
guardando su queste proprio risparmio
dai girato e non capito cosa intendo
[Musica]
non so se sia sicuro grafica no
con la prova si ritiene che sia più
bella del mio super colorati bello mio
perdono l'edizione d'aiuto non voglio
tirare magari lo scambiamo mi muovo novo
per veramente io dall'iso il video il
vostro mostrano che capitano attentati
ecco il motivo perchè doveva ricapitato
istituti sono il crimine odioso più
strano è che bello noi vediamo la volta
attiva altro numero 3 in via purtroppo
credo la lazio ne questa ci stanno tutti
bene e rende bello e lattico questo mi
metto dentro di strano alla nazione il
colorante verde il play il film o la
colla
speriamo questi scambi
[Musica]
numero 3 nuovamente apprendiamo le
conchiglie sono bianche viola ha parlato
[Musica]
di lattine che ingredienti sono di
destra con nordi male che continuerà a
mario che toccamenti morosa numero uno
vediamo un po famiglia ed io non lo do
per aiutare in piedi perche i migliori
adesso punti magari il premio più basso
della malattia
[Musica]
c'erano bloccando anch'io di chi sa chi
ok a picconate bellissimo finalmente di
sistema un po costo slime ma che è il
colore alla fine qualcosa è brutto ma
devono aggiustare voler dare è adesso
mettiamo una tonnellata così diventa
bello e colorato e diventa di nuovo team
mate non potrò mai diventare merger osta
[Musica]
numero 3
la maledizione del verde è tornata anche
di clay verde quindi non sonic lei si
sta male ma è anche perde però io
pensavo all'inizio di questo gioco che
non mi sembra capire se dietro che il
nostro attende è tornato man ga e julien
ricaricato dal tattico nel mio slime
bellissimo
ecco qua sono sicure che ci sta vedi wow
proviamo a rischiarlo vediamo già a una
posizione già spende un posto pulito
hai visto non deve neanche votare per
organizzarle non so proprio come
diventerà che almeno sono ci sono le
palline viola che danno un po di colore
diverso sono veramente strano vediamo il
tuo se cambia il colore sono consistenza
stranissima questo non era mica diciamo
melanina la fa diventare del fluido non
newtoniano non so nemmeno se riuscirai
ad attivarlo c'è fortuna ma ti mangiano
posta schiena in un sacco e tornare a
bianco tipo siano altrui tipo round
entrambi quindi speriamo che si capì di
qualcosa che
l'ultimo migliore amico stretto capaci
con il miracolo dove dentro un miracolo
ma dentro ci è sembrato vai
[Musica]
scatta la numero 3 ma siccome l'ultimo
round non aprirla ancora simile vediamo
come stata capita gambe no no questo
blog mi aspetta però che non è vero
perché la scatola a raggiungere
l'obiettivo da raggiungere o qui allora
facciamo così scambio con la scala si è
ridotto io voglio un giorno slide verde
va bene tanto abbiamo finalmente bird
contento che poi turi volta è riuscito a
rovinare lo stato non sono stato un po
la direzione di auto grigia visto dai
temi che questa sia la salvezza salvezza
equa 3 1 per l'inter a stare col colore
il colore che colore sarà bello la
cosiddetta non lo stop a lenin proprio
quel che c'è un bottone staccare la
stessa banda come già cena povera anche
tu sei anche verde mega che non va sotto
i figli era un pezzo che per fortuna ha
ridato indietro della schifezza mediale
siamo ad attivarlo che brutto brutto
manuale è normale che dello steri
ripresa ora proviamo ad attivarli e poi
vediamo chi vince è che iniziamo con il
news l'aims allora il colore è un
cosa chiaro la consistenza è veramente
particolare perché penso che sia per la
farina
comunque è un po inquieta non lo so come
descriverlo
e poi la forza dove si sono i fili e
stranissima che è come sembra
cioè si faccia la parte qui eccoli
eccoli guardatevelo attento intrappolati
però insomma non ci sta lo farete bene
questi tiri perché lo strappano vedete
con dio eccolo qua zitto frutto quindi
questi fili non si stanno per mente bene
però fa dei suoni e canti ma si informa
gigante masticata però poi si vedono le
tante palline colorate dentro almeno
quindi più sly un po particolare dargli
un voto da 1 a 10 per aspetto e per sony
srg qua e casi qua questo è il mio stile
di colore molto particolare molto bello
quasi fosforescente ricordiamoci 1000
1000 ingredienti che ci sono 22 clay 1
verde uno bianco le fishbowl la
spugnetta è un po particolare quindi non
è super allungabile proprio proprio
perché c'è il play però comunque non è
male dai che bello voi le palline viola
ci stanno ci stanno benissimo
banalmente ancora 1 persona su una
facebook sentiamo i suoni
produrre un po particolare è un po odore
un odore un po sembra schiuma da barba
ma in realtà è che quel momento siamo
arrivati al cooking
perfetta mentre migliaia di zombie
online ma non è il tipo di sliven data
da pochi non è bellino ho perso due
facebook ma va bene o per sé senza
patemi mettiamo di forma tutto qua
dentro
votate per me perché è troppo bello e
del verde le piace al suo il derby piace
a tutti tra natalita così sa che questa
cosa qui tutto quel che lei è normale
che gara sulle spugnetta che ascoltano
[Musica]
anche qui potete votare per me arrivano
http caliti prova ci sono scritto ti
dice se la siamo qua quando i caratteri
evidente pubblicare nella tutela sociale
sui nostri video divertenti i nostri
esperimenti che non su quella che
preferite
buona visione ciao